[موسيقى]
إنها الساعة 4:00 صباحًا هنا في
دبي، الوقت مبكر جدًا ولكننا
هنا لتحطيم الرقم القياسي العالمي [
موسيقى]
لذا فإن تحدي اللياقة البدنية هو
مبادرة حكومية، نحن الآن في
عامنا السابع و  نحاول بشكل أساسي لمدة 30
يومًا تشجيع الجميع على ممارسة
التمارين الرياضية لمدة 30 دقيقة على الأقل، وهذا حدث ضخم لم نكن أبدًا
جزءًا من شيء كبير كهذا قبل أن نكون
متحمسين حقًا لرؤية كيف وصلنا هذا
الصباح، نحن مستعدون كفريق نحن من أجله
تمرين لا يصدق اليوم، من الرائع جدًا
رؤية العديد من الأشخاص المختلفين من
جميع أنحاء العالم، لذلك دعونا
نغلق أنفسنا ونستعد للمضي قدمًا، أيها الفريق الصحيح، لقد
بدأنا، نحن نصل إلى هناك، هل
أنت مستعد 3 2 واحد، دعنا نسير على ما يرام
إذن
نعم، مشهد اللياقة البدنية في دبي مستمر في
النمو لقد جئت إلى هنا منذ 7 سنوات والآن
يستمر في النمو وهذا ما
أحبه في هذا المكان، حيث
تقام دائمًا أحداث كبيرة وضخمة وهو المكان الذي يجب أن
أكون فيه، كما تعلم أنها
البيئة المثالية لأحداث مثل اليوم  نحن في
منتصف الطريق يا رفاق، كلنا نتعرق،
لدينا 15 دقيقة إضافية،
المبادرات مثل تحدي دبي للياقة البدنية
رائعة لأنها
حدث واحد خلال الشهر حيث يشارك الجميع
في المدينة على طول الطريق من
الرياضيين إلى الأشخاص العاديين في جميع أنحاء
خلال تحدي اللياقة البدنية،
توجد نوافذ منبثقة، وهناك قرى لياقة مختلفة،
ومثلما هو الحال اليوم،
حدث ضخم مذهل في
محاولة تسجيل الأرقام القياسية في موسوعة غينيس، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم على
انضمامكم إلينا هنا هذا الصباح يا رفاق،
إنها 30 دقيقة كما ترون العمل الشاق للغاية الذي قمنا به  لقد
حصلنا على
هذا الصباح مجهودًا كبيرًا من الجميع
هنا الآن نيابة عن موسوعة غينيس للأرقام القياسية،
يمكنني أن
أعلن رسميًا أنك اليوم قد
حطمت رسميًا لقبًا جديدًا في موسوعة غينيس، تهانينا
لحقيقة أنه كان لدينا
آلاف الأشخاص هنا حرفيًا
وكانوا كذلك.  كما تعلمون، الصراخ
والحيوية والصراخ كان
خارج السلسلة، لقد كان ملحميًا للغاية، لذا
نعم، إذا كان صوتي خشنًا بعض الشيء،
فهذا لأنني كنت أهتف
وأصيح طوال الـ 30 إلى 45 دقيقة الماضية، لقد
فعلنا ذلك أصحاب الرقم القياسي العالمي هنا  في
دبي فعلنا ما أتينا من أجله، إنه
شعور جيد، شعور جيد للغاية، نحن
أصحاب الرقم القياسي العالمي، لقد فعلنا ذلك
فريقًا